hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll and today we're talking about a
subject that is near and dear to the
hearts of most everyone out there money
we all know when money is right we use
money we exchange it for goods and
services as Homer Simpson once pointed
out but we also get this feeling that
the notion of money is in flux right now
the notion of currency the actual thing
you give to somebody which used to be
dollar bills of course it's increasingly
credit one way or the other
and these days there's this talk of
crypto currencies like Bitcoin in
aetherium and so forth
somehow the computer scientists have
gotten their hands on money and the
world might never be the same the
question is how is this new world going
to look if you followed the Bitcoin
situation at all you know there's a bit
of instability in the system Bitcoin was
supposed to be a way that people could
use it as money to exchange for things
on the internet but the actual value of
bitcoins has been fluctuating wildly if
you were really really good and bought
it very very cheaply early on you could
have made an enormous amount of cash
good old American dollars if you had
sold it at the right time but now it's
on its way back down this doesn't sound
like something that we could reliably
use as money but the hype is not from
nowhere there's reasons why people are
very excited about crypto currencies so
today's guest is Nahan Narula and she's
the one to talk to you about this Neha
is the director of the digital currency
initiative at MIT and she's an expert on
not only crypto currencies but wide
scale scalable computing online security
things like that so we're going to
actually sit down and talk about what
the blockchain is this technology that
some of you are I'm sure super experts
on but other of you don't quite know
what's going on so you will by the end
of this episode you'll understand the
blockchain there may be talk of hash
functions it's a it's a crazy world out
there we need to understand some new
concepts but that's okay it will all
make sense after this hour and it
matters not just for money but for the
future of the internet which affects us
in a number of ways the internet more
oddly has gone from this kind of
wild-west individualistic view that we
had back in the 90s let's say to a set
of mega platforms Facebook and Google
and Amazon and Twitter that seemed to
control an increasing fraction of what
goes on online so the same technologies
that are behind cryptocurrencies might
someday help bring back the situation
where things were a little bit more
individualistic a little bit more
decentralized and that could have
crucial impacts on how we use the
Internet
a decade or two from now so let's go
[Music]
great May hot Narula
welcome to the mindscape podcast hello
so I'm gonna be even more than usual
asking the dumbest silliest most
straightforward questions because I
think we're gonna talk about sexy stuff
right crypto currencies Bitcoin
distributed computing on the internet
and privacy and things like that and
this is very important stuff but it's
also stuff where jargon gets in the way
very very quickly so I'm not going to be
embarrassed I'm going to play the
village idiot and ask sillies questions
so let's start with what is money you
know honestly I I'm getting more and
more convinced by the day that like that
no one really knows what money is it's a
very very confusing topic and the more I
read about it I think the less I
understand which is you know not a great
sign so economists define money as
having three qualities it is a unit of
account we use it to price things we say
how much things are worth but in terms
of money in terms of dollars for example
as a medium of exchange so we use money
to buy things to make exchanges to have
to transact and have an economy sure and
then the third way the third sort of
property that defines money is as a
store of value so we use money to store
value you know we work and get a
paycheck we put our paycheck in a
savings account that's money so that we
can use that money for a rainy day so
that's sort of the technical definition
of money now that was excellent by the
way I didn't expect you to have quite
such a very detailed answer right on the
bat but I guess as are you what I do is
there an economics angle - you're sort
of training and interest or is it more
no I am a computer scientist right
background and I did not have any
economics training but you kind of have
to sort of you know start to curb a
little bit together and so I would say
I'm still very early in that process but
you know I can quote a couple things
that economists might say so you've been
picking it up on street corners highway
trying to yes learn
genomics on the street that's a great
way of describing it my type of street
level economics so you know breed you
know yeah talking to your friendly
neighborhood dropout or something like
that right that's what's been going on
um so so you know so that's like the
economists definition which is one way
of looking at it another way of looking
at it is money is the way I like to say
talk about it is that money is a story
because some money's a story that we
tell ourselves you know I let's say I'm
pulling a $20 bill out of my pocket
right now why does this piece of paper
mean anything why is it worth anything
it's worth something because we we tell
a story to each other about why it's
worth something and we all sort of
believe in that story and we interact as
though that story is true that story
being that this $20 is worth you know
approximately I don't know maybe a nice
lunch somewheres worth of value and you
know if I give it to you you can go buy
a nice lunch somewhere and and with that
money that person can go buy something
else somewhere so so money is a story
that we tell each other and we've all
sort of agreed to use certain objects or
pieces of paper or ones and zeroes in
certain databases as accounts for how
much money we all have and we use it to
transact and it's very much based on
sort of an absurd level of trust between
people who've never met each other right
yeah yeah walk into a store and a piece
of plastic and walk out with stuff
exactly it's kind of amazing when you
think about it right you know that I can
interact with someone I've never met
before might not even like might not
trust at all and yet we can have a
transaction and you know a transaction
that would normally require a
relationship may be weapons or something
to back it up we can have a transaction
because of things like money and and so
it's it's a really a very powerful thing
it's something that society really needs
and it facilitates sort of the exchange
of value in our economies and there is
at least this one major split between
the idea of using something for money
that has an intrinsic worth right like
gold or silver or whatever versus you
using more abstract notions of money
well I'm gonna I'm gonna push back on
you a little bit there because um this
intrinsic worth thing is actually a
really interesting question and you know
a lot of people do see it that way
they're like okay I get it dollar bills
those are paper though they're not
actually worth something if something's
printed on them and that's why I think
they're valuable but gold gold is
actually worth something why is gold you
know it's like it's it's Turtles all the
way down is what I got to say like you
know gold is not actually doesn't have
intrinsic value which equates to the
amount that it's worth in our society
today yes you can use gold as you know
in some electronics yes we like to wear
gold rings on our fingers sometimes but
but really gold is another story that we
all tell ourselves we've all decided for
a very very long time that gold is a is
going to be a measure of wealth for us
that we're going to use it to store
value and so that's what it is well
that's great because I think that
actually a theme of many of the
conversations I'm having is taking ideas
that are you might naturally think of as
very very different and seeing that
they're actually kind of blurry between
them right and you're pointing out that
there isn't really any cut-and-dried
thing called intrinsic value different
people might value even you know bread
or water very differently from each
other yes yes that is very very true you
know things have different value to
different people things like art you
know of course this is a very incredibly
different value to different people we
try to negotiate that using prices and
value and things like that
but sort of you know thinking about
things like gold and silver and whatnot
they're precious metals that have
certain properties that make them
convenient to use as a store of value
but that doesn't make them inherently
valuable so in some sense the very idea
of money has a bit of arbitrariness
built into it or a bit of a convention
built into it and we shouldn't be afraid
of that we should figure out how to use
it does that okay yes I think that we
shouldn't be afraid of it we should
acknowledge it I mean I mean I'm a big
proponent of acknowledging the truth and
instead of trying to ignore it and we
should acknowledge it we should note it
and we should you know not try to hold
things like you know other forms of
money to a different standard right in
fact this morning I have to you know
share this with the podcast audience
out there because we're at this
wonderful little event called Kent
presents where we a lot of people give
talks to an interested public and you
made a billion dollars this morning
within a few minutes can you tell us by
what magic you did that yes I did I
obtained a very high market
capitalization so yes I can explain how
I did that so previously what I'd done
is I'd spent about five minutes creating
something called a smart contract on
something called a cryptocurrency
so um so so I I created my own token out
of nowhere basically so I decided that
there were going to be a billion of them
I was gonna name them Nahas shares you
know their shares of me there's a
billion of them and I created them I
them into existence and then they don't
correspond to a billion things out here
in the world we just sat down and said
billion yes I just sat down and said I'm
making up this thing called Nijo shares
and there are a billion of them and I so
I deem it to be um and nothing so
prosaic is actually real things you know
that's just ridiculous
so um it just so happens I'm keeping
track of these Neha shares somewhere on
the Internet
and and then I went in front of this
audience here at Kent presents and I
said would any of you be willing to buy
an A assure from me for $1 and lo and
behold I think there were three people
who raised their hands
you know my shares weren't worth that
much but some people are willing to sort
of take a chance and with those if I
made those three sales then given the
fact that there are a billion Neha
shares and I just sold three of them for
$3 well that gives me a market cap of a
billion dollars billion dollars right
there in dollars right there you tend to
be cashed in right away um you know I
was I was gonna go get some VC money
actually and see if I could up that a
bit yeah well it again I think it's good
because it helps tear down a little bit
of these artificial distinctions we draw
so the same thing could be said of the
stock portfolio in your retirement fund
right it's you say you think you're
worth certain amount of money well
that's because you'd think people would
pay you that amount of money for those
shares and
if you just have cash under the mattress
you still are trusting that it has some
value in some market exactly I the
reason I like that example so much is
because first of all it pokes fun at you
know crazy high market caps of startups
or cryptocurrencies or whatever right
it's the last share you sold and you
multiply that times the number of
outstanding shares but also yeah it just
makes you realize that um I
I've always thought of something I've
used to always think of money as being
sort of static right like if I had a
thousand dollars I had a thousand
dollars if I didn't spend it I would
have the same amount tomorrow and in
fact you know the world is a bit of a
harsh place and it is actually very
difficult to store value and to really
ensure that it's gonna be worth the same
amount tomorrow and so yeah your star
stock portfolio could crash tomorrow you
know even if you're storing things in
dollars under your mattress maybe
there's some great financial calamity
and the the euro dollar ratio changes
dramatically and all of a sudden you
can't import that nice Swiss cheese
anymore all these things are sort of
floating and ephemeral and they're very
difficult to pin down and it's not even
unrealistic Larry's right hyperinflation
has been known to wipe out fortunes it
happens wrong it's happening right now
in different countries yes yeah so what
are some of the problems with the
current system when it comes to money in
terms of how useful the current system
of cash and credit cards and so forth is
in doing the exchanges we want to do
around the world yeah so I think some of
the the so there's definitely problems
with payments I think that the bigger
problem lies and who happens to hold
most of the wealth in the world and who
doesn't we live in a pretty unequal
society it's tremendously unequal in
particular you know about twelve really
large investment banks basically kind of
run things move around trillions and
trillions of dollars worth of value
every day and and it's it's kind of
insane when you think about the fact
that some people make decisions you know
like where to go to college right well
oh I can't afford that school so I'm
gonna go to this other school that maybe
isn't as good for me and we're talking
maybe you know
thousands of dollars of difference or
tens of thousands into an investment
bank that's like a rounding error and so
you know it when I started to really
unpack what was value it was wealth what
was money realizing that that all of
this was true just made me think what is
going on with our financial system such
that if someone can graduate college
with tens of that or hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt that they
that they can't get rid of that you know
Puerto Rico is is suffering from this
massive hurricane and owes all this
money to its bondholders yeah the world
is just a really strange place and it
really made me feel like we needed to
kind of upend things a little but we
really needed to think about is our
financial system working for us doesn't
make sense
is this the way that we want it to work
and if the answer to that is no and I
think the answer to that is no then how
are we going to change it and you point
specifically I get a little bit
surprised again not an expert in any of
these things but to investment banks
rather than you know Amazon and Apple
and alphabet or Petro dollars or Russian
oligarchs so it's really the investment
banks you think where the wealth is
concentrated in the current system I
think that they happen to have a lot of
power in the current system yes I think
that they do a lot of expertise as well
you know yeah I think when we're talking
about sure we can talk about Google and
Apple and Facebook and all the problems
with their platforms and user data and
those are really big problems they're
also really big problems which maybe
this technology has a chance of
affecting I don't know you know one
thing at a time we can't fix the whole
world right at once
so what do you think about okay so
there's problems with that obviously
inequality I completely agree with you
also problems I gather you know in
certain parts of the world or whatever
there's just sort of friction in the
system there's too much of a barrier to
using cash in the easy way that we're
used to here in the US for example yeah
definitely so um I think there's a lot
of places in the world where people just
quite simply don't have access to
digital financial services it just
doesn't exist
one of my colleagues like to talk about
a place in South America or someone had
to like
in a canoe and like canoe really far to
get to Lake a town and maybe the bank
was open maybe it wasn't open and it was
just this like really arduous horrible
experience to get access to financial
services like loans and savings accounts
and and digital payments and things like
that so that is that is definitely a
huge huge problem I think that the
general statistic that's thrown around
is that there are about 2 billion
unbanked people in the world so so
that's that's an issue some people don't
like to use the word unbanked because it
implies the people should be banked well
you know and and that's not 100% clear
but the basic ideas don't have access to
financial services that might be helpful
for them that might help them improve
the quality of their lives so that's a
major major problem and the reason that
these people don't have access to these
financial services is because no
institution has deigned to give them
access right and there are different
reasons for that it might be incredibly
expensive in order to reach these people
it also might be the case that it's too
confusing to understand how to sort of
value the creditworthiness of these
people so there are a lot of different
reasons but the simple fact of the
matter is no access and I think we need
to change that alright so we've
identified the problem what are we gonna
do about them you are you know the
leader of a digital currency initiative
as I take it and so maybe your answer
has something to do with digital
currencies yeah it might just have
something to do with digital currencies
ah so I I to be clear and I want to
state this upfront it's not that I
necessarily think that this is the
absolute answer to all of these problems
that is probably not true it's more that
I think it might be part of an answer to
these problems and even that is to me
good enough reason to work on it and to
try to try to make this stuff happen
I've heard a lot of stories about people
who have used cryptocurrency to solve
some of their problems and the stories
have been very moving actually people
who nor at this point in time most of
the stories I hear are about either they
fall into sort of one of two categories
one category is I earn money in one
country and I want to put it in another
country and by using something like
Bitcoin I'm able to do that much more
cheaply than I would otherwise
so remittances cross-border payments
okay that type of use case the other use
case that I hear about is people from
countries who wear their currency is
under capital controls or it's getting
hyperinflation and this offers them a
means of taking the wealth that they've
accumulated and getting it out before it
disappears
so it's about wealth preservation do you
have a specific moving story that you
have in mind when you're thinking about
great question so in the first category
there was a gentleman who lives and
works in Nigeria and needs to come to
Boston occasionally and there just
wasn't really a great way for him to to
move money every month into into from
Nigerian currency to American currency
it's just it was complicated and
extremely expensive and it just it
didn't work and bitcoin was a solution
for him for the the wealth side of
things I have a friend who runs a
cryptocurrency company called Zappo and
he's from Argentina and so he went
through he saw sort of that happening in
Argentina and it was really powerful for
him and he really saw a lot of potential
in cryptocurrency and that's why he
works on it today alright so we're at
the point where you don't have to tell
us what a cryptocurrency is what Bitcoin
is there's something called the
blockchain
we have danced around for this so so a
great question so where do we start I
you know I like to start with Bitcoin
because that's how it started and
chronologically I think is a pretty good
way to try to describe it so um in 2008
this shadowy figure on the internet
known only as Satoshi Nakamoto sent an
email to a mailing list and said hey I
have this idea I'm calling it Bitcoin
and Satoshi Nakamoto he she they we have
no idea who this person or persons this
who they are then released a white paper
describing Bitcoin in explaining the
idea behind it and the idea behind it
was peer-to-peer payments without any
bank or government or other institution
facilitating those payments here it's
very detailed Stephenson right it's very
science fiction novel like some
shadowy figure who no one knows what
they are it starts a revolution such a
great movie one day I can't wait for the
movie a version of this Aaron Sorkin if
you're listening
give us a call think about it have your
people contact um so uh so right so so
then a few months later Satoshi actually
produced working code Satoshi said hey
I've I've programmed this here it is I'm
running it if you would like you can run
it too and we will be part of the same
network and that will be Bitcoin and so
people in this mailing list we're like
hey this is kind of neat okay fine oh
and by the way if you run this you get
two you get Bitcoin by just by running
it right now you are your computer's
gonna sort of spin and do a salt trying
to solve a little problem and every time
it solves a problem first it's going to
get a bit of Bitcoin and so people
started doing it they started this
process is called mining they started
mining Bitcoin and then you know this
progressed for about three years or so I
would say and then there's two years
anyway a few years right it was just
sort of this toy it was this weird thing
that some people on the internet were
playing with him were using and we're
liking and actually this goes back to
the stories they were all telling
themselves a sort of story about it and
right this was a an unhackable form of
money this was money that no one could
take from you it was purely based on
mathematics
it was um you know it was very pure form
of Internet money and then what happened
next was and it's also happened on the
internet some guy said hey I'm hungry I
would like to buy two pizzas if you send
me two pizzas I will send you forty
thousand Bitcoin and this is what's
known as the first exchange for Bitcoin
for something of actual value the first
time someone bought something to please
two pizzas forty thousand billions yeah
why am I not on these mailing way so uh
so what happened somebody in London sent
this guy two pizzas he's he was in
Florida and he sent him the other guy
forty thousand Bitcoin which let's not
talk about how how much that's worth in
today's amount of money tens millions of
dollars so so those pizzas were
delicious because I think it was Papa
John's
so um so that was the first time that
yeah Bitcoin was actually exchanged for
something and that was the first thing
that you could really say this is how
much a bitcoins worth you know take the
cost of a pizza / 40,000 and then it
just sort of went on this crazy ride of
gaining value and losing value and it
was all about you know it's all about
the story of Bitcoin and what's four and
what you know how do we use it and what
does it mean and since then there's been
even more crypto currencies I think
there are thousands of them out there
right now and in part a lot of that is
about experimentation people sort of
trying out different ideas trying to see
what makes these things work and what
makes this doesn't work what doesn't
work but going back to sort of the
question about okay there's bitcoin is
cryptocurrency what is a blockchain well
in satoshis paper Satoshi talked about a
chain of blocks and underlying now I
understand oh yeah that's right makes so
much more sense now
Bitcoin coin made a bit what's so
confusing about all of this so so
Satoshi talked about sort of the
structure of this ledger so the idea
behind bitcoins remember so she said hey
I'm running this code anybody else want
to run it here it is
anybody could download and run this code
anybody you could download and run it
right now it's still the case anybody
can download and run this code join the
network and start being a part of
Bitcoin sorry the code
to do what but there's well the code to
to try to create blocks and to download
the blocks other people have created
check them to make sure they're correct
and sort of facilitate the transfer of
your Bitcoin and so for is there one
blockchain for each currency so there's
one blockchain for Bitcoin kind of so at
its heart the blockchain is a data
structure ledger of transactions Bitcoin
has its own blockchain there's one
blockchain for Bitcoin however there's
something called forking basically
someone can decide to divide the network
up and basically create a copy of
Bitcoin new network new
speciation another blockchain yes it's
like so you know it's like um you know a
creature just divides itself into two
that's basically what happens so so then
there's another blockchain so that and
Bitcoin is this has happened to Bitcoin
several times there's a few variants of
it there's a Bitcoin cash Bitcoin Gold
Bitcoin platinum you did it a hard one
in addition to that there are other
cryptocurrencies that do have their own
block chains like aetherium is another
one litecoin is another one z cash is
another one and then this is where it
gets really confusing there are ways of
building tokens on top of other block
chains so this is actually really common
with aetherium and this is what I did in
the talk this morning at the conference
where we are
you can etherium is a little bit
different than Bitcoin or s bitcoins a
ledger of transactions aetherium is kind
of more like a global computer it runs
it doesn't just handle transactions
which make payments it handles something
called smart contracts which are like
little programs you can write a little
program and throw it on the etherium
blockchain and then that little program
will execute and so one very very
popular type of program is one in which
you can create your own token token is
and a token is just like those niha
share something that someone makes up
it's digital it doesn't exist in the
real world there's hopefully a limited
amount of them that are an issuance
schedule that's controlled
programmatically and it's like a digital
credit you know it's just it's it's just
sometimes they're made in a context
where the idea is that they're supposed
to correspond to something right I was
gonna say at some point just like the
pizza is they have to be assigned value
yes yes and so sometimes that's done by
again the story we all tell ourselves
like that how like as happens with money
and sometimes that's done because
there's somebody sort of behind it
saying this tokens gonna be worth
something
for example Starbucks points might be
thought of as tokens right these are
airline sort of frequent flyer points
yeah exactly
so there are a lot of people these days
who are developing their own network
and are creating tokens to go along with
those networks and sort of suggesting
that people will buy tokens in order to
use whatever service that network
provides okay I would I this is great
and I want to come back to it but I
definitely want to get this blockchain
stuff completely understood so in some
sense the blockchain let's just take the
particular blockchain for your favorite
Bitcoin fork right there just one
blockchain so it's a set of ones and
zeros right it's a file yeah except it's
not just one file it's a file that
exists on many computers at once yes is
that right and whenever any transaction
happens with Bitcoin you add that to
everyone's file and then there's a way
of sort of checking that no one's
cheating yes that is exactly what
happens um so this computer network is
every computer in it every every soft
every node in the network is keeping a
file just like you said and that is an
append-only file and what you do is you
add transactions to that to that to the
end of that file and that file is a copy
of a ledger that everyone's maintaining
together the reason it's called a block
chain in particular is because instead
of adding transactions one at a time you
group them together in a set and then
you just stick the set onto the end of
the file and that's called a block it's
a block of transactions so it's just
sort of like a batching mechanism you
just put them together in one chunk
the reason it's a chain is because each
set of transactions each block points to
the one before it so it's kind of it's
like this list this sum it's like a
linked list in computer science
terminology and what this serves to do
is it makes the blockchain tamper proof
but you can't go back in time and fiddle
with the transactions because if you do
you're gonna mess up all the pointers
and the pointers aren't gonna work out
correctly anymore and that's gonna be
very obvious to everyone they're gonna
notice and and also everyone else's and
if you try to do anything to the
blockchain it's just automatic then
everyone's file updates great question
so this is where this process called
mining comes in so in order in Bitcoin
in particular in order to create a new
block a new set
transactions I myself for example might
be doing this I'm gonna gather a bunch
of people's transactions together stick
them in a block and then try to solve a
random numeric puzzle that's what I'm
gonna do
this was Satoshi's idea Toshi's idea
this is Satoshi's idea he he or she or
they had this idea that what will happen
is we'll all sit there and our computers
will spin trying different random
numbers and the way I like to think
about this problem is imagine you have
let's say you have 10 dice okay and
you're gonna throw the dice and let's
say you know you throw the dice once
maybe a number's repeated it a couple
times but you know probably are gonna
get sort of a random assortment of
numbers each time now let's say I told
you if you throw those 10 dice and you
get all sixes then you win the game
that's winning the game that's kind of
the puzzle that that everyone's trying
to solve on their computer it's like
they're throwing dice generating random
numbers until that number looks a
certain way and once they do that they
publish their answer and people check it
to make sure that they actually did this
right and that is the process by which
several different things happen first of
all that set of blocks needs that
special random number attached to it in
order to be a valid block in the
blockchain and then second the fact that
I generated that random number allows me
to create new Bitcoin out of nowhere
according to a schedule that is set in
the computer program so so this is and
this is the process known as mining
right Bitcoin mining who made up the
puzzle the who knows what the right
answer is is it unknown or is it
universal it's it's uh so everyone knows
sort of the sketch of the problem right
and it's um it's actually something
called finding the preimage of a hash so
there are these things called hash
functions in cryptography and what they
do is they take a large amount of data
and they map it onto fingerprints okay
so it's a way of sort of fingerprinting
data now when you do that the
fingerprint comes out looking sort of
random okay but like a fingerprint we
don't mean a set of
swirls on a piece of paper we've got
some 1 0-0 so we need we mean a little
chunk of data yes another chunk of data
so you take a big chunk of data like a
PDF or an email or a picture and you
feed it through this hash function and
what comes out the other end is a short
string that is sort of very uniquely
tied to that piece of data you put
inside and it's shorter than the
original much much shorter it can be
much much shorter than the original okay
the same size of the original and so um
and so what this does is it serves to
sort of like you know if I take a
picture and I and I put it through a
hash function and fingerprint and create
this sort of hash that describes the
picture that summarizes in a way then
that means if you show me a different
picture I can hash it and and see that
the hashes will turn out different so so
hash functions are used to sort of
uniquely identify big chunks of data
that's why I call them a fingerprint
it's because the fingerprint is kind of
like a unique representation of me
except sorry to keep interrupting but if
a big file gets hashed into a small file
then mustn't it follow that multiple big
files would give you the same small
absolutely absolutely true in fact it is
the case that for any sort of single
hash or fingerprint there are many many
many many many things that will hash to
that thing okay but a property of a hash
function is that it is extraordinarily
difficult to find something so just
given the short string the hash the
fingerprint it is very difficult for me
to work backwards from that or something
that will hash to that value that
difficult problem is exactly what's
going on with Bitcoin mining so what's
happening is your computers trying
different large different streams over
and over and over again to see if they
produce the right kind of fingerprint
okay in fact produce a short string with
a lot of zeros at the front at this
point in time I think given the way
Bitcoin mining is works you needs a but
you need about like seventy zero in the
front that's actually a really hard hard
thing to do
but someone knows the hash function the
hash file everybody knows the hash mark
my functions called sha-256 I see
inverting it is inverting it is extra
you can know the hash function and
that's still you still can't invert it
very easily and this is just a miracle
of math this is a really cool property
of math and cryptography yes
and so Satoshi is the one who picked
sha-256 as the particular hash function
that we were going to use for Bitcoin
good and so when someone so the mining
that we always hear about is people it
used to be individuals on their little
laptops now as gigantic farms in China
and elsewhere chugging through little
tiny fingerprints trying to reconstruct
what they were hashing yes
so what's and it's worth talking about
that a little bit yeah so when Satoshi
started he or she or they thought that
oh great everyone will run this on their
computers and and and you know computers
are pretty powerful you can check and
check a bunch of different combinations
of data to see if they produce the right
hash and then while we're in Bitcoin
together on our computers now what ended
up happening is that you know clever
people realized that it was possible to
develop specialized hardware that could
do this faster than people's laptops and
if they could do it faster that means
that they had a better chance of finding
the answer first and winning the Bitcoin
that grows out of this process and so
this kind of started an arms race of
crazy hardware development and now there
are these machines called Asics
application-specific integrated circuits
that can solve this problem millions of
times faster than your laptop can and
basically you can't mine in the Bitcoin
network effectively unless you have one
of these machines and different
cryptocurrencies actually use slightly
different hash functions so if some use
sha-256 others use different things and
it's very interesting because Nvidia a
lot of people have been buying GPUs to
mine cryptocurrency and so Nvidia was
like who's buying all of our GPUs and
what's going on why is the computer
circuit company yeah they make the
graphics processing unit that goes on
your computer it's frequently used for
gaming you need
I like a fancy GPU to in order to render
your video game nicely and shoot the bad
guy and so lo and behold cryptocurrency
enthusiasts are competing with gamers
and driving up the prices of GPUs which
I find very funny very devoted fan bases
for different reasons but ok that was
extremely helpful but let's let's bring
it back down so the blockchain so this
is how we make so what do we call it
when we successfully mine we got a
Bitcoin we you mind a block you mind a
block
yes yes ok and as and what is stored on
any individual computer in the network
is the entire blockchain so in the
spirit of asking the dumb questions
doesn't it get really big it's about 50
gigabytes right now pretty big it's
pretty big you don't actually have to
store the whole thing you just kind of
need to get it and verify it and then
once you catch up you're good you can
kind of throw it away
oh come so so there's that you don't
have to keep it forever
you just have to process it all so you
know it is entirely possible there's a
thing you have to remember about the
space is that it's still pretty early on
we're still at the beginning bitcoin was
the first cryptocurrency and yes in
Bitcoin you have to keep a history of
every transaction that ever existed but
there's people working on really cool
ideas that let you do things like keep a
constant amount of space that proves
that you've looked at every transaction
that's ever existed and verified it so
you know I the way I like to think about
this
I like making an analogy to cars so in
the early 1900's cars were very clunky
very slow use a lot of gas horses were
faster than cars but you know they got
better very very very quickly and I
think cryptocurrencies are kind of the
same way yeah there's a lot of problems
right now but we're still working on
them and I think there I see solutions
in sight and this drives home the
messages that we started with really so
you you've mined a Bitcoin you well you
mind a block and you get rewarded with
some Bitcoin when that happens right and
basically I could translate that
statement into you have solved a math
puzzle you're Nvidia card on your
computer has solved a math puzzle and
the rest of the world agrees to then
exchange some little information you
have for money yeah of course the amount
of money
seems to change from day to day but
that's basically it you you have this
piece of information that verifies that
you solved this puzzle and will give you
hundreds of dollars for that well we'll
give you I think right now it's 12.5
Bitcoin for that okay however many
dollars that is might change by the time
this podcast is definitely yes yes okay
and so what makes this so great there's
a way to for people around the world to
agree on some token worth some value why
is that better than good old American
dollars great question I think they're
both pretty great one or the other you
know um so so first of all one thing
that it wasn't immediately obvious to me
but I realized later was Bitcoin was the
first time that people made digital
payments without a bank without a bank
that's a point yeah almost going back to
bartering it is it's going back to
something that's very sort of
peer-to-peer very sort of you know you
don't need this very highly regulated
structured institution that does very
specific things in the middle you don't
need that anymore you can do digital
payments without a bank so that in
itself is pretty cool like you probably
want to know what like so what right
digital payments through banks they seem
to work fine you know we we've survived
this long and I think that that's very
true in a lot of cultures and a lot of
different societies digital payments
through credit cards and banks are fine
the fee we have to pay is kind of
annoying
you know actually merchants pay it and
then they pass it on to us or we don't
think we pay fees for credit cards but
actually we're paying for it and the
goods that we buy the fee around 2.7
percent you know could it be lower I
don't know maybe cryptocurrencies could
help push that feel a little lower but
that's not really groundbreaking right
saving like a percent here and there um
but you know I think it what's really is
kind of groundbreaking is going back to
what we were talking about earlier
there's so many people in the world who
just don't have access to digital
financial services and this is a way
that if they can get an internet
connection they have access BAM done
they don't need a bank to sign them up
they
don't need to be KY seed or am L they
don't have to have a minimum deposit
size or a certain type of identification
they can just start doing it which is
kind of neat
and reminds me very much of another
piece of technology which is sort of
what we call permissionless which is the
Internet it's another thing where you
can kind of just start using it and just
to get the excuse me the technical
detail right here as I understand it if
you own some cryptocurrencies a Bitcoin
or aetherium or whatever you have a
number that you're supposed to not lose
and if you use this you've it's lost
it's no longer yours and the number I
read on the internet was twenty billion
dollars is estimate to have been
misplaced by people losing their
addresses what do they call the what is
the phrase the private yeah yeah yeah
we're still figuring this all out this
it's not ready for primetime
absolutely right so um so yeah so this
is called public key cryptography and it
was actually invented in the 70s and it
was invented at MIT one of my a
professor I work with occasionally named
Ron Rivest was pretty critical and its
invention and the IEEE and it actually
it's used on the Internet in so many
different places public key cryptography
is critical for security for hiding
information and for proving the
integrity of information so the way that
it's used in cryptocurrencies is as
follows people have a private key and a
public key and you can generate these on
your computer it's just sort of randomly
you kind of throw some randomness in
there and you get these two numbers out
and they work together so normally when
I log on to a service on the internet I
type in my password right so my password
is something that I should keep secret
I'm not supposed to show anybody except
I'm supposed to type it into a form and
then send it over the Internet to this
company that's the way password works a
password this is not how public key
cryptography works the way that this
works is I have two pieces of
information one's public and one's
private the private one I never share
with anybody I never ever ever I'm not
supposed to ever give anyone my private
key
I use my private key to either digitally
sign things so like producing a
signature or to encrypt things digitally
encrypting meanings sort of like mask
them and then people use the public
counterpart to that my public key to
either validate that the signature came
from me or to to encrypt stuff for me
so actually use my private key to
decrypt things but so so this is how
these two sort of pieces are work two
pieces are used together it's a very
different way of thinking it's very
different and so yeah when you're
working with a company or a website on
the Internet if you lose your password
no problem you gotta you can call him up
you can click the password reset button
though they'll reset your account before
you remember the street you grew up on
or whatever your first cat they have all
sorts of annoying questions they will
ask you to confirm it's you but they
have a way to reset your password give
you access back to your account that's
because there's a company with a list of
all the accounts and they can do that
they can go into their database and they
can just flip something around with
crypto currencies like Bitcoin there's
no company right the everybody's
computer like everybody's computers are
running these things it's this
distributed decentralized system and so
if you lose your private key nobody's
gonna be able to give that back to you
and nobody can reset your account for
you that's kind of the point and so yeah
you're kind of out of luck if you happen
to lose it you or someone steals it they
can steal your money which is kind of a
bummer but like you get it we're still
in the process of setting up what will
be the more user-friendly interfaces for
all and I think you know just to talk
about that a little I think it'll be
layered so yes at the bottom layer there
will be sort of this public-private key
infrastructure and if you ultimately
lose sometimes you can actually use
multiple keys so you can kind of keep
them in different places so like you can
give your dad one and your brother
another one and then you know they can
reconstruct it for you like there's sort
of techniques that you can use to make
this problem a little less bad and what
will happen is I think you know yeah
there'll be companies that figure out
how to use these techniques and then
they'll offer a service to users and our
users will use these companies
ooh intermediate their access to the
cryptocurrency in places like coinbase
are trying to do this yeah exactly so
coin base is probably the biggest
cryptocurrency company so they you can
buy and sell cryptocurrencies through
coin base and that this is a large part
of what they do they make try to make it
easy for users you don't have to worry
about public keys and private keys the
thing is is that when you hold
cryptocurrency through a company like
coinbase you're not actually holding it
yourself they're holding it you have an
account at coinbase it's a little bit
more like a banking like a bank but yeah
but it's not sort of governmental
currency but it's the cryptocurrency
exactly I think a lot of people get
confused between the difference between
thinking of these cryptocurrencies as
investment instruments versus actual
things you use to make payments and in
fact it's still not that easy to pay for
things using Bitcoin or a theory people
invest in them and that may or may not
be a good idea yeah well I think there's
a few different things going on here
really is first of all there is there
are digital payments and that was kind
of the pitch of Bitcoin in the beginning
was this is a new form of making digital
payments but it's kind of a slow system
for digital payments I think there's a
new technology coming that's gonna make
things a lot faster but it's not quite
here yet so um you know still in its
infancy but then there's also this idea
of remember we were talking about niha
shares and me issuing my own token
there's kind of this notion of like well
why can't I just issue shares in myself
or shares in my idea right why can't I
just create that out of nowhere and
allow you to invest in it you get a
share you get a promise and and I think
these ideas are connected in a way
because they're they're all about sort
of disentangling the instruments of
Finance from trusted institutions and
the very intense regulation that goes
around those institutions is about it's
about breaking that apart and
reimagining how we might do these things
if we weren't so encumbered right but I
mostly want as a way to charge people
$0.10 every time they listen to a
podcast episode is that something that
digital currencies will help with their
do you think so I think we're getting
closer to that yes there are so one of
the major problems with Bitcoin is it
had kind of has high fees you still have
to pick up exactly so there's still
friction and this is yeah I know that
was the whole province and and part of
the reason for that is going back to it
remember everyone's storing a copy of
this ledger right
so when I create my one little
transaction it gets stored thousands of
times around the world which is kind of
a little excessive I don't know it needs
to be stored that many times and that's
costly right it costs money to pay for
the bandwidth to move that around to pay
for the disk space to store it to pay
for the CPU to validate it and so you
know it's for good reason it's a little
bit pricier to create a Bitcoin
transaction there are really interesting
solutions coming down the pipeline to
help make all of that much much much
much cheaper and I'm really excited
about this and I think it will make it
so that you can very easily take
one-time $0.10 payments no problem or
even maybe what you should do is you
should charge people like a cent per
second of podcast they listen to so oh
they'll keep going ok keep paying you
can have you can put all the juicy stuff
at the other well so what do what would
you say I mean there's been a lot of
hype right a lot of speculation a lot of
promise about these things I can see how
once things are up and running a little
bit more accessible these kinds of
currencies will help people in different
parts of the world get access to money
or even even more than access to money
access to finance right access to the
ability to do things with with this kind
of money and and hopefully the friction
will be less like hopefully the
transaction cost will be less like so
what is the biggest way you see that
this might change the world if you're
being at your most optimistic mood ok
well I mean so we won't hold it to you
yeah how do you do it
sort of well ok I'll start with
something abstract so the goal that I
work on and that my group works on is we
want to create what we called the
internet of value so what the internet
did for information we want to do for
the transfer of value and so what I
think in terms of
platforms and infrastructure and so I
want to create the platforms and
infrastructure so that people can build
applications which move around value and
sort of transform value and create
contracts and things like that so I want
to build the infrastructure that will
let you really really easily you know
with a few lines of code or a service or
whatever start to take payments for your
podcasts like tiny little micro payments
for your podcast so I think that
building that infrastructure I don't
even know what people are gonna do with
it but I think it could be really
exciting similarly to the ways that with
the internet we didn't really know what
people were gonna do about it we didn't
know that it was gonna sort of
facilitate Arab Spring or change the
outcome of an election in the United
States or or you know all the things
that it did I met my wife through the
internet oh that's great we've read each
other's blogs and that's probably good
to know each other yeah really yeah yeah
how far apart were you guys I was in
Chicago and she was in Washington DC and
what was it about her blog well this was
the early go-go days of blogging in
general and there weren't that many
physics blogs on the internet and most
of them were written by physicists who
are not very good writers so Jennifer is
a professional writer and so she was
writing about physics in a much more
charming way than most people so I you
know said hi and we exchanged questions
about how to be a good blogger and so
forth
then it was it turned out that we were
gonna appear at the same physics
conference in a few weeks and 12 years
later
yes happily married definitely married
yeah that's adorable you met on the
internet yeah a big fan of the internet
even like Twitter and the only one I
also like Twitter i love/hate
relationship definitely but lots of love
there too yeah so um you know internet
bringing people together yeah exactly of
love is one of the things that could
come out of this so abstractly that's
what I'm really interested in when it
comes to sort of concrete specifics I
get a little bit more sort of I you know
I don't know I I think access is just a
really big thing giving people access to
financial services letting them you know
build all sorts of crazy types of things
with them
and there's also a very dystopian view
so something I really worry about a lot
are micropayments and what kinds of
things micro payments might facilitate
so to give you an example right now
there's a lot of stuff that we just get
for free because it's not really
feasible to charge for it
right so sitting on a park bench or a
water fountain or things like that
there's a lot of sort of like I see
where this is going
yeah this could get bad you want to
charge a cent per second of your podcast
what if someone wants to start charging
who knows what like you know tolls for
example what if you paid always paint
tolls and it's like every single mile
you drove on whatever Road and
everything sort of varied and it was
very much like sort of this varied
pricing and and and like the way that
sort of plane tickets kind of operate
right now where people are charging
different prices depending on time and
availability and it just feels really
unfair you know it feels really weird to
have that happen in our society so I
worry that if we create a world where
taking payments and charging for things
it just becomes orders of magnitude
easier than what that might do that's a
little scary so you're saying that the
ability to charge people to do anything
has downsides yeah all right I can see
that sometimes sometimes I think about
you know it's money really a good thing
is owning property really a good thing I
start to get very little crazy yeah the
other things start getting a little but
it did remedy that maybe we can talk
about yo beyond money there's this
bigger philosophy of decentralization
and on the Internet in particular you
know and I know that you've you thought
about this a little bit money is an
example where there's a central
authority who prints the money and
decides what the supply is the internet
was originally maybe at least in our
retelling of it as sort of Wild West
libertarian frontier where individuals
ruggedly did their thing and now
evermore there are gatekeepers there are
sort of mega platforms that rule
everything is this is the blockchain
technology something that can move us
back toward a more individualistic
approach or should we just do that
anyway we're you know regardless of the
role of the watching
yeah that's a great question um so the
Internet
yes the internet definitely has this
mythology attached to it of Oh anybody
you know in the beginning anyone could
run a server anyone could put their
content up it was findable by anyone
very much like that lovely story about
you and your wife and how you met you
both like put your content out there you
did and you found each other right it
you didn't have to be friends on
Facebook it was just you found each
other through your ideas and that was
sort of the promise of the Internet and
now it is all mediated by these giant
platforms and we've actually done quite
a bit of thinking and writing about this
topic because there is a big push to
quote-unquote ridi centralize the web
right and what does that mean that means
lots of different things so first of all
people are very worried about the power
that the central that these centralized
platforms have over our society over
public discourse
there's algorithmic bias in the ways
that they operate their censorship and
and people sort of feel trapped you know
there's this feeling like well I don't
really like Facebook but I don't really
have any other option like that's where
all your friends are yeah what am I
gonna do where I won't seem photos of my
nephew if I'm not on Facebook what it
means to be a monopoly yeah and and and
I think really the when you look at the
way that cryptocurrencies operate
there's this it's the protocol is very
much not about monopolies it's about
users individuals owning their own data
and so people are applying those ideas
to the Internet in general and so
there's been a big push to think about
data portability mmm-hmm what does that
mean that means you know I put a lot of
content onto these services I should be
able to get it out whenever I want at
the click of a button and I should be
able to move it so if someone develops
face planner I don't know if some other
competitor to Facebook write some new
social network I should be able to move
my data out of Facebook BAM into this
other thing with the click of a button
and I should be able to you know another
sort of next step of that
interoperability is even if I'm on a
different social network I should still
be able to interact
the people who stayed behind on the
other sounding very utopian right now
compared to the present yes it's the
prize the original idea behind the
internet though is it would use these
interoperable protocols and so everybody
would be able to talk to everybody else
so I think this is you know it's it does
sound a little bit like a pipe dream
given the way that things work right now
a but people are trying to push things
in this direction and is the blockchain
playing a role there or is it simply
sort of philosophically aligned so some
people will say that the blockchain can
play a role there I don't I'm not 100%
convinced of that I think it's more of
the inspiration right but somehow the
blockchain technology goes hand in hand
with the idea of privacy security being
able to be ourselves be recognized as
ourselves and that might help right yeah
well so there's a few different things
at play here so first of all the public
key cryptography I was talking about is
a way of me identifying myself that
doesn't require any sort of central
registry necessarily I kind of like it's
a consistent sort of digital I it can be
a consistent digital identity so you
lose it yeah until until it someone
steals it or you lose it that's a whole
nother conversation to start to have so
that's kind of an idea of like can I
have a digital identity that is separate
from these services and then another
idea is this idea of decentralization
and in particulars no central body
there's no one you know we're all
coordinating together we're all working
on this together and we're all we're all
figuring it out this this together
because you have to realize the way that
crypto currencies like Bitcoin work is
there's no there's no like fence around
them it's not the case like with most
sort of systems when you think about
protecting them you think okay there's
gonna be a firewall a perimeter and I'm
gonna keep hackers out I'm not gonna let
the hackers in but if the hackers get in
if they cross the perimeter all bets are
off with Bitcoin there's no perimeter
anybody can get in at any time
the Bitcoin invites the hackers in so to
speak the hackers are in there they're
all hanging out with you right but it's
designed in such a way
by using digital signatures and by
creating this strange game of mining the
hackers won't be able to spend my money
and they will be incentivized to
participate in a productive way instead
of attacking the system so it sounds
like I mean there was a time very very
brief when there were not only blogs but
then there were RSS readers yes
so you could I'm the only person
Jennifer and I are the only people who
still use our zones every day yeah try
occasionally and just give up and for
people who are too young to know what
this was you know you would have blogs
or other news services without and
whatever and they would have a feed and
you could choose what sources to let
into your feet so I can read both like
my friends blogs and the New York Times
on in the same platform and you could
imagine a way better version of that
because the technology has not been
improved really for a decade that was
the equivalent of Facebook and Twitter
and the New York Times and your friends
pictures and whatever and in trolls by
you right yet you can you know I think
that what people realize is this is not
a way to make money right under the
present system and I think that's one
thing I think the other thing is of
course a slight level of technological
sophistication is required to jump into
that and navigate it effectively and
Facebook you know for all its
terribleness
made it really easy for everyone to go
in and post their pictures yep this is a
big problem with decentralized systems
they are very hard to use and if there's
no giant company sitting in the middle
of it making a ton of money who's paying
for the UI designer and user experience
engineers and the people who are gonna
actually sort of make this thing work
right and as an empirical matter you
know you can try to crowdsource it but
those are not the issues that are often
most of interest to the people coding
away for free you have this publicly
first thing right so Linux as much as we
love it it's just not as user friendly
as Mac OS or whatever yeah yeah yeah
it's a little worrisome and another
related thing before I forget is you
mentioned this morning electric voting
electron
voting right will these friends of
technologies help make that more secure
well we're really meeting like I sit at
my laptop and I can vote it right you
need to go in or like on my mobile phone
yeah thing like that that's the dream
right is like I take out my phone and I
and I vote I don't have to stand in line
I don't have to worry about sort of like
who's checking to make sure I register
or people turning me away so some of
these technologies yes will be extremely
helpful for electronic voting
cryptography using public private key
pairs and things like that but you know
the big the big push that I've heard
about is applying blockchain technology
to voting and I'm actually very
skeptical about that right now
the thing with electronic voting is that
it's so important electronic voting is
critically important and the thing with
paper is that it's kind of hard to hack
paper at scale
it's a perfected technology paper yeah
it really is quite difficult to affect
all the paper in a really big country at
the same time right right you you kinda
have to but it's considerably easier to
electronically change things even in a
wide geographical area at one time if
you if you hack the system if you find a
flaw if you find a way in and so with
electronic voting you're kind of opening
up your attack surface quite a bit now
it's not just about the voting machines
it's about the phone that you're voting
on the computer you're voting on your
internet connection from your house so
many different things the entire
software stack of what's running so many
things that if there's a bug in any one
of those things your vote could be
compromised so we really have to be very
very careful about getting it right and
blockchain technology doesn't help with
any of that end point stuff it doesn't
help make sure that my I didn't install
some weird piece of software that's
sitting there fiddling with my vote I'll
talk to you in touch technologies and do
anything about that and so um I you know
I just don't think it's solving the
right the real problems there was a this
brilliant xkcd cartoon as they so often
are recently that was you know talking
to an airline technician or an airplane
technician and they will say it's it
seems unsafe to be an airplane they can
crash but it's really SuperDuper safe
way more safe you know
car technician same thing and then an
electronic voting software developer
he's like no don't ever use this for
anything this is incredibly subject to
being exploited exactly and I think when
you talk to the experts in the space
they will all say this they will all say
no no no no don't try to use these we
like first of all a start-up do you
really want to start up developing like
mission critical infrastructure for your
country no no no they've only existed
for like six months and who are these
people you know this is not exuberant
audited and and really really really
secure looked at by like everybody so I
don't understand I I know people are
very frustrated with voting and they
really want to increase access right and
I I very much understand that that
problem in that question I just I want
to urge caution is there a worry what
about the social side of the
individuality aspect if everyone
controls their own feed if everyone you
know makes their own internet do we
worry about political polarization kind
of questions hacking by BOTS stuff like
that you know we just very recently had
the incidents where Alex Jones and
various conspiracy theorists and Nazis
been kicked off of certain mega
platforms is that the good side of the
mega platforms that they can control
that exactly this is something that
we've also thought about and written
about a little bit so there is an
alternative to Twitter called Mastodon
it is a federated form of Twitter it's
very hip I don't you might want I
thought that hip yeah I should become
more hip so Mastodon yes it's it's sort
of a federated Twitter and by that I
mean different people run different
Mastodon instances and so but they all
interoperate you can subscribe to people
in these different instances but the
idea is if somebody kicks you off of one
you can just get on another one it's a
you know it's a bit harder to censor
guess what these things are breeding
grounds for the type of things that get
kicked off of Twitter which are not
really very savory sorts of things yeah
and so so it's it's sort of the the
counterpoint to censorship resistant
technology that means that you really
can't censor things that maybe even as a
society we would want censored so aside
from what you think
happen or worried about what might
happen what do you think will happen I'm
here I just remember you know in the
mid-1990s when web pages first began to
become a thing right mosaic and Netscape
and so forth and I was very early
adopter for these things and I got very
excited and I could not explain to my
friends why I was excited like I'm sure
this is gonna be really important and
they said well what is it good for
I said well look you can get a
photograph of whether the coffee machine
has coffee in it or not like there's
this is not worth what you're what
you're talking about but of course we
use the internet for a lot now yes
probably many of the applications are
going to be unanticipated I guess yes
and please don't ask me to anticipate
them I feel exactly the same way that
you do like look I did this cool thing
where I wrote this like transaction that
did this weird thing and they're like
what like I don't need that yeah and
it's just the sense that there's
something neat here there's something
that we can do here that we couldn't do
before and I don't know how we're gonna
do it but it's a platform people will
build a million things on top of it and
some of those things will be super
amazing and cool all right
Nana Narula will come back ten years
from now and we'll have a good laugh as
well we thought the internet was going
to be thanks so much for being on the
podcast thank you
[Music]